tech giants like Facebook Amazon uber
and we work have all faced criticism for
their workplace culture well venture
capitalist ben horowitz argues that many
companies missed the mark when
developing their culture it's part of
his new book what you do is who you are
how to create your business culture
Horowitz was an investor in
transformative startups like Airbnb
Instagram lyft and Pinterest and he
joins us now Ben good morning good
morning so I I think we should define
culture because you have an interesting
way of saying look it's not dogs at work
it's not casual Friday it's not a bunch
of slogans on the wall so then what is
it yeah well and it's not a set of
beliefs it's a set of actions and so
it's what people do when you're not
looking and you're not there so do they
go home at 5:00 or do they go home at
8:00 do they return that phone call that
day or in a week you know when they do a
partnership do they focus on the
partnership itself around the price and
these kinds of things are your culture
and they're very hard to measure and you
can't just put them in a performance
review because you don't even know if
they did them and you said there's a
difference between culture and perks at
work and sometimes people get it
confused and you have to have big buy-in
from the CEO whoever she is yes yeah yes
no absolutely and but they won't just
behave like the CEO yes like when you
all come to work you just don't say uh
what would the CEO of CBS do yes right
like the culture has to be programmed it
has to be systematic so as a leader you
can't just expect that people are gonna
do what you do that doesn't happen in
the book you remind us about Facebook's
early motto which was move fast and
break things yes which was very good at
the time at the time well that's one
thing that happens companies grow in
effect you have to change in a way no
absolutely you have to change because
when the world changes as it has changed
for Facebook and then like your business
needs change and what you have to do
changes and because your culture is how
you behave
your behavior needs to change and your
culture has to evolve and often you know
when you start a company you can't
anticipate all the things that you're
going to need yeah I'd like to when you
talk about Ben about hiring practices I
found this very interesting of people in
it
our positions only hire people that look
like them yeah that really does hurt the
culture and you had a really graphic
example about one of your one of your
managers told you yeah and it's not just
so like when you're hiring people you
generally your default is you hire you
like I know what I'm good at I value
that highly I can test for it in an
interview right but then you don't see
people I have talent that you don't have
and the thing that really drove this
home for me as I had an organization
with all women in it and I asked the
manager I'm like what is it about your
job criteria where no men can get the
job I was just trying to understand it
and she said helpfulness and I was like
snap but we were a services firm yeah
and like being able to anticipate some
of these needs being able to be helpful
was like a really critical thing we
needed in the firm but I can even see it
I was blind to that talent so it
actually takes work to see talent that
you yourself don't have but it's a huge
competitive advantage if you can do it
yeah and I think people default to when
they get into diversity and inclusion
they go well I'll just look at the X
Allah oh that's a woman that's a like
you know african-american that's yes but
that doesn't get what you want
and it also corrupts the culture because
now you're making race and gender the
criteria as opposed to seeing the talent
there are big questions right now in
criticisms and calls for big tech
overall to be regulated Elizabeth Warren
is calling for a breakup of many of the
big-name tech companies it is changing
culture a way of kind of regulating from
the inside well I think so I mean you
know and gets into more complex things
but I think people often misinterpret
kind of and you all see this a lot kind
of good versus evil like that's a good
person that's versus you know humans
against the gods it's a systems problem
we're all battling this system that
we've created and it's very complicated
and it's hard to understand what the
consequences are and so it takes work to
reprogram it and correct it and that's a
lot of what culture is about how do you
get the system to where it does what you
want it to do so it's a good system not
an evil system right but like if you go
to like the
tenth of Jeff Beezus and Mark Zuckerberg
you've had them on like none of these
people have bad intention they all have
very good intentions any execution but
it's complex to get it right and you
know particularly when you talk about
like something with billions of people
on it your book is good cuz use three
different examples with Genghis Khan
Chaka Sakura who was a gang leader in
prison and then Toussaint L'Ouverture
cultures that worked yes maybe you'll
come back and do a podcast with me what
you do is who you are goes on sale
tomorrow we'll be right back